Le visage de cette fillette a bouleversé la
France entière. 11 août 1987 à hauteur de Suèvres,
des employés de l'autoroute découvrent
le corps sans vie d'une fillette. Elle
est vraisemblablement âgée de 3 à 5 ans
et porte une robe à carreaux. Morsures,
traces de fer à repasser, coups et contusions...
l'autopsie révélera plus tard de multiples mauvais
traitement antérieurs à son décès. A l'époque, il
n'est pas encore question de relevés d'empreintes
génétiques seul son groupe sanguin est identifié.
Peu après sa mort, l'enfant est enterrée sur la
commune de Suèvres. Kléber Cousin en était le
maire à l'époque : "pour nous ça a été une grosse
affaire, pénible, très pénible. Mais nous
l'avons vécue et puis nous le vivons encore,
voyez toutes ces fleurs qui sont encore, il y a
beaucoup d'artificielles mais il y a encore des
naturelles. Mais vous avez des gens de passage
ayant appris cette triste affaire par la presse,
des gens de passage s'arrêtent et cherchent le
cimetière de Suèvres pour voir à cette petite
tombe. Pour nous c'est la petite de l'A10 et
ce sera toujours la petite de l'A10. En 1993,
Jacques Pradel et son émission témoin numéro
1 relance l'affaire. Les gendarmes reçoivent
de nombreux appels et tentent quelques pistes,
l'une d'entre elles les conduira en Tunisie, et
puis plus rien. Les juges se succèdent et en 1997
un non lieu est prononcé. En 2007, quelques mois
avant la prescription définitive, le procureur
de la république de Blois ouvre une nouvelle
information judiciaire pour mauvais traitements
sur mineur, homicide et recel de cadavre.
Et justement avant de poursuivre ce journal,
cet appel à témoin lancé par la justice,
regardez : un numéro de téléphone le 06
46 17 05 59. Le signalement, l'appel à
témoin : un enfant 95 cm, vous le voyez, 20 kg,
cheveux bruns bouclés, les yeux noirs, 3 à 5 ans,
elle portait une robe bleue et blanche
à carreaux de type méditerranéen. Voilà.